we're from the cast of marvel studios
eternals it's time to play choose for
eternity okay get ready for it what
dinner would you eat for all of eternity
quesadillas
it's gotta be biryani sunday rest with
all the trimmings it's gonna be
breakfast for dinner anything with
cheese and eggs i'm at it this is really
good girl what would you drink grape
cooler mescal
vanilla milkshakes vodka you're on an
eternal road trip who are you at my
family and the eternals i gotta say my
wife emily because sh she might watch
this richard madden
what outfit would you wear for all
eternity pajamas pajamas
a onesie that has the buttons in the
back because that's just easy can only
have one ice cream flavor what is it
oh my god really you're asking me this
this is the rudest question mango
chocolate bone marrow and cherries what
i feel like vanilla gets like short
shrift everyone thinks vanilla is so
vanilla but vanilla is really good what
movie would you watch for all of
eternity eternals it's gonna sound like
i'm biased but marvel studios eternal it
is time marvel studios eternals is in
theaters november 5th book your tickets
today